[Music]
no no
no he's not a cop he can't be wearing
any of this it's just a windbreaker it's
not like i gave him a badge and a gun he
has both of those things it's not loaded
i just want to [ __ ] it and say a cool
cop catchphrase
new york's finest just got a whole lot
finer peralta it's no coincidence you're
on this ship you want a free cruise
without entering a contest how do you
think that happened i don't know maybe
it's because i bought speed two on dvd
and the internet realized that cruises
were one of my interests great film
sandy being a sarong damn straight but
the ticks are all me i brought you here
cause i'm in peril peril don't put my
apparel somebody's trying to kill me and
i need protection so i set for my best
friend i am not your best friend i'm
your worst enemy get that through your
head it's this kind of bickering that
makes us such an adorable couple
whatever judy you're under arrest you
can't arrest me boo we're in
international waters which is also why i
can smoke as much weed as i want welcome
to the high seas no no way that that's
true amy tell me i can arrest him right
now judy's right we have no jurisdiction
technically this boat flies under the
flag of uzbekistan uh-oh your girl knows
about the oozebacks
oh but do you know how many crimes we're
forgiving six that's not so bad a
hundred oh that's way more grand theft
auto grand theft auto grand theft auto
dog fraud i saw the guy fake peeking
knees
towards the cat you will not win me over
with your use of twas i wasn't trying to
you're clearly friends with this man and
you've lost your objectivity peralta or
have you lost your objectivity what are
you doing my bad thought we were leaving
no i'm just making a point yourself
since i'm going to jail i want to enjoy
my time left on the outside
put me up in a five-star hotel like the
royce
unlimited room service in many of our
privileges three-star hotel like the
brooklyner 60 a day meal allowance no
mini bar four-star hotel like the oneida
200 in food no mini bar or alcohol but i
get to go crazy on candy and nuts
agreed oh
oh one last thing diaz has to be nice to
me i want her to call me
big sugar ah huge mistake bud she'll
never agree to that no i'm in let's do
this big sugar oh what all right fine if
this is going down i want to be on this
case and my sole focus is doug judy he
never leaves my sights love it pontiac
bandit and jake pb and jay right again
reunited and it feels so good
so do i get all this
reunited cause we understand no no okay
so you guys are rich europeans looking
about shelby i'll make the introductions
wait we can't just be europeans what
country are we from what languages do
you speak french
spanish
some portuguese obviously greek enough
flemish to get by tight what about you
peralta um i can do a pretty good
italian accent
you think you could milk me
so you're just doing de niro from meet
the parents i don't know am i that's a
terrible de niro i don't know this is
narrow i think it's pretty good
pretty good we'll just make america okay
i gotta say the suit is growing on me
looks good is it triple breasted somehow
there's no such thing what about the
girl in total recall um
gotta admit man i thought you'd be
happier to see me being so weird oh i
don't know i didn't sleep well last
night so i'm probably tired from that oh
and also this is a hostage situation wow
it's like that yes it's like that what
the hell i thought you went straight i
did i'm a high-end car broker now i
procure luxury vehicles for the rich and
famous and i do it legally last week i
dropped off a bugatti to the key of the
list from stranger things you meant
dustin was he cool do him and the rest
of the gang hang out in real life you
know what no we are not chatting right
now you have three hostages you mean pam
and the two bombs they're not hostages i
prefer to call them collateral
friendships i gave them each 500 bucks
out of my own pocket thanks again doug
you the man doug actually i'd rather
still not be a hostage pam hasn't come
around on me yet tell i'm a nice person
jake i'm sorry officer are you friends
with this criminal no not really
absolutely best friend it's a layered
relationship pam just friends
judy smosh smosh
who still sounded like an angel you sure
thank god you were there peralta i know
you wouldn't let your best friend die
i'm still gonna arrest you i just can't
do that if you're dead whatever you
gotta tell yourself
baby steps it's hard getting him out of
his shell tell me about it every time we
get emotional he's like noice smort okay
can we focus up here lobster thermador
baked alaska it's so fancy don't even
sound like food
here come on order something or do it
all right no thanks i'm on duty come on
peralta you gonna let the criminal have
all the fun
all right fine
i'll have one lobster thermador extra
thermador on the side i have no idea
what i'm ordering me neither we're like
culinary magellans you know how we take
this to the next level robes robes
[Music]
i mean nobody saw him but there was a
prolific car thief at the scene of the
crime you're talking about me i'm a cop
now no you're not do i don't have a
badge and a gun
the thin blue line just got thick as
hell come on judy it's not loaded look
if i was gonna jack a bunch of cars i
wouldn't bring two of new york's best
detectives with me to the scene of the
crime flattery you think you're the best
this is nonsense you're off the case
whoa whoa sir come on we're chasing a
murderer a murderer that just stole a
ton of cars who knows more about that
world than doug judy plus remember he
doesn't get immunity unless he helps us
bring his brother in i know but do you
want to get back gertie or not
fine he's still on the case oh the
pontiac bandit nj got cops with the
wives cracking captain along for the
ride they'll have the pictures wherever
they go the talking dog flies in outer
space
earth earth
yes you won't take your deal they think
you're lying i'm not lying i don't want
to be a criminal i love my life as an
average citizen i voted for the first
time this year ed breakfast for school
board who i don't know he had a funny
name he deserves a shot that's why i
voted for stacy ladle anyways i'm sorry
but they're not cutting a deal so that's
it i got to turn myself in and let
halloway kill my mama actually
there might be another way to get this
done
i'm taking your negotiator hostage if
you come in here i will shoot him just
do whatever he says
my life is in his hands
ah that was so much fun oh man you
sounded really scary no no it was all
you the tremble in your voice soldier
just do whatever he wants i just made
that up oh i was so in the moment dude
seriously you are a great hostage oh
thanks judy you're a great hostage taker
where is judy i've looked everywhere he
has to be somewhere on this boat
no he doesn't
i'm sorry to do this to you man i saw an
opening and i had to take i can't go to
jail i'm too cool you'll never get away
from me judy i can't hear what you're
saying you're real far away
i'll just assume you're finally
admitting we're best friends no that is
not what i'm saying thank you
means a lot to me enjoy the rest of your
crew just remember you got a five lady
don't be a tang in the mud
check your pockets
boom boom stay room baby
awesome
but this isn't over i will hug you to
the ends of the earth i love you too
i'm so proud of us for being able to say
it what are you still standing there for
go smush judy no
we'll be safe here i know the owner he
never turned me in yeah i have the exact
same relationship with the guy who runs
the laser tag place i love i mean gun
range peralta who you out here stunned
for huh
i love laser t we gotta go sometime man
ah i was hoping you say that that wasn't
stunting a little bit no stunting it's
stunning a little bit
i've got this coupon for a private room
yes right this way
we already have some queued up for you
judy what's up peralta thank you so much
for coming look i thought about it and
i did you dirty i never meant to cause
you any troubles yeah well you caused me
a lot i'm talking to a pre-recorded
video but it's cool i know what you're
saying i hear you in my heart what am i
doing here i feel the same way you're my
best friend too look i'm not coming back
i started a new life here in san diego
stupid telling me where you are come on
man i ain't no damn san diego everybody
knows that place subs here's what i want
to say though i'm sorry i won't be at
your wedding but i did record you a cd
of original shmush jams that will
consummate the marriage it's on the
table next to you along with a little
something else
a french gorilla crusade pot now look
inside it
the diamonds yes
i cannot believe you actually brought
the diamonds
yeah this time that one no you're the
best look even though i am a scorpion i
will never drown your adorable little
frog ass so that's what i had to say i'm
sure i'll see you again at some point
now that coupon you got there it's for a
full hour in the private room
so
[Music]
so
i was going home
you